ABC has canceled roseann bars TV show
this afternoon's announcement comes
following a tweet from the comic which
most people found not funny at all but
rather abhorrent
here's Fox News media analyst and host
of Fox's media buzz Howard Kurtz
Roseanne Barr had been on top of the
world a resurrected show featuring her
as a pro Trump housewife a huge hit for
ABC look at her ratings but hours ago in
the blink of a tweet ABC cancelled
Roseanne over the stars ugly comments
about former Obama White House official
Valerie Jarrett comments the network
called abhorrent repugnant and
inconsistent with our values the
offending tweet using Jarrett's initials
said if Muslim Brotherhood and Planet of
the Apes had a baby equals VJ Jared is
black so the a preference caused a
social media uproar but at first Barr
did not back off when Twitter users call
the line racist bar responded that
Muslims are not a race she later tweeted
that she'd been making a joke before
finally saying this I apologized to
Valerie Jarrett and to all Americans I
am truly sorry for making a bad joke
about her politics and her looks but the
outrage mounted actress Wanda Sykes who
worked with the program said she would
not be returning next season bars talent
agency ICM dropped her al Sharpton said
that comparing Jarrett to an ape is
racist and inexcusable ABC must take
action now many other comedians have
survived offensive jokes Stephen Colbert
made a sexual crack about President
Trump and Vladimir Putin Kathy Griffin
is mounting a comeback after posing with
a bloody trump mask Wanda Sykes herself
once called Rush Limbaugh the 20th
hijacker who failed to show up on 9/11
because of a drug addiction a key
difference bars mockery of Jared touch
the third rail of race the furor
prompted Bob Iger the CEO of parent
company Disney to say there was only one
thing to do here and that was the right
thing ABC acted with stunning swiftness
to protect its brand although the show
had been very lucrative in this
hyperpolarized Twitter era a network's
reputation can be tarnished
quickly as a top star can self-destruct
right Howie thanks White House press
secretary Sarah Sanders aboard Air Force
One refused to comment on the roseanne
cancellation asked multiple times about
it she replied to these numerous
questions by saying the president is
focused on other things so what do you
think what's your reaction to the
roseanne cancellation let me know on
twitter at bret baier you can use the
hashtag special report we're on facebook
at facebook.com slash Bret Baier Sr